[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen guten Abend
wünsche ich Ihnen alles Wichtige vom
Sport erfahren Sie von Rudi Cerne hallo
schönen guten Abend schauen wir uns
unsere Themen heute
China droht Taiwan Militärmanöver Proben
die Einkreisung der Insel Peking spricht
von einer Warnung an separatistische
Kräfte
zerstrittene Friedensfreunde
konkurrierende Ostermärsche in
zahlreichen Städten die Linkspartei
zeigt sich zerrissen
und sie gegen die Niederlande
Deutschlands Fußball Frauen freuen sich
über ein glückliches 1:0 bei den
Vize-Weltmeisterin
der Nervenkrieg zwischen China und
Taiwan geht in eine neue Runde nach dem
Besuch von Taiwans
präsidentiner Stärke demonstrieren und
startete heute militär-
offensichtlich
unbeeindrucktems Präsidentin zur selben
Zeit eine Delegation von amerikanischen
Abgeordneten in der Hauptstadt Taipeh
was Peking als Provokation ansieht das
chinesische Militärmanöver im Gebiet
rund um Taiwan und in der Taiwanstraße
einer viel befahrenen schifffahrtsroute
soll noch bis übermorgen andauern Miriam
Steiner berichtet
nirgendwo in China ist man der
taiwan-insel so nah wie hier auf pink
tan gerade einmal 140 Kilometer sind es
viele kommen extra um Taiwan von hier
aus sehen zu können
ich bin noch jung und hoffe dass wir
Taiwan zu meinen Lebzeiten zurückerobern
werden
denn China betrachtet das demokratische
Taiwan als Teil seines Staatsgebiets die
Wiedervereinigung wie er es nennt ist
das erklärte Ziel von staatschefsi den
Ping ich hoffe dass wir Taiwan auf
friedliche Weise zurückgewinnen können
die Übungen sind schließlich nur eine
Atem unsere nationale Stärke zu
demonstrieren
rund um Taiwan sieht es heute alles
andere als friedlich aus neun
chinesische Kriegsschiffe und 71
Militärflugzeuge zählt das taiwanesische
Verteidigungsministerium die Übung will
Chinas Armee als Warnung an
separatistische Kräfte verstanden wissen
in der Hauptstadt von Taiwan wird sie
vor allem als Bedrohung empfunden
dass ich sagen und tun kann was ich will
die Militärmanöver werden als Reaktion
gewertet auf den Besuch von Taiwans
Präsidentin in den USA dort hatte sie
sich vergangene Woche mit dem Sprecher
des Repräsentantenhauses getroffen china
macht die USA für die Instabilität in
der Taiwanstraße verantwortlich die
Reaktion aus Taiwan heute
Taiwan liebt Demokratie und Frieden und
will seine Verantwortung in der
internationalen Gemeinschaft wahrnehmen
wir werden weiterhin mit den USA und
Gleichgesinnten zusammenarbeiten
Freiheit und Demokratie verteidigen bis
Montag will das chinesische Militär
seine Manöver rund um Taiwan fortsetzen
auch im Nahen Osten ist die Lage zur
Zeit angespannt wie lange nicht erst
wurde Israel aus Gaza und dem Libanon
mit Raketen beschossen Israel antwortete
mit Gegenschlägen gestern Abend wurde
erneut ein Anschlag verübt den Tel Aviv
wurde ein italienischer Tourist getötet
sieben Menschen wurden verletzt ein
Bericht von Michael Beverungen
es sind verstörende Bilder von der
telaviva Strandpromenade aufgezeichnet
von einer Überwachungskamera ein
wagenwechsel plötzlich mit hoher
Geschwindigkeit auf den Fußgängerweg
erfasst Passanten und überschlägt sich
die Polizei erschießt den Attentäter die
Bilanz seiner Amokfahrt sieben zum Teil
schwer verletzte ein italienischer
Urlaub bestimmt die Opfer ausnahmslos
Touristen
der Tatort am Tag danach Touristen und
Einheimische regieren jeweils auf ihre
Weise
er fühlt sich sicher und dann abends
wenn man die Nachrichten durchschaut
sieht man wieder oder hört man wieder
liest mal wieder von den Anschlag das
ist eigentlich nicht zu fassen
auch wenn Sie noch mehr Unschuldige
töten das wird nichts ändern die
Menschen werden weiterleben und
weiterhin den strandbesuchen
der mutmaßliche Täter ein arabischer
Israeli
während die radikalislamische hamast den
Terroranschlag als legitim rechtfertigt
haben ihn arabische israelische
Politiker scharf verurteilt Gewalt gegen
Bürger sei niemals zu rechtfertigen
unabhängig von Religion Ethnie oder
Nationalität
gestern hat es einen weiteren Anschlag
mit zwei Toten gegeben premierte tanjao
hatte daraufhin angekündigt
unsere Feinde versuchen uns auszutesten
aber wieder einmal werden Sie
feststellen dass wir zusammen stehen
vereint und auf Gerechtigkeit vertrauent
werden wir gemeinsam handeln und unsere
Sicherheitskräfte unterstützen
Polizeikräfte sollen nun verstärkt so
wie weitere Armee Reservisten eingezogen
werden
[Musik]
seit neun Jahren ist die Krim
mittlerweile russisch besetzt die
Befreiung der Halbinsel sei nach wie vor
alternativlos bekräftigt jetzt der
ukrainische Präsident selenski und weiß
damit den Vorschlag des brasilianischen
Präsidenten Lula zurück für einen
Frieden möglicherweise auf die Krim zu
verzichten alle Menschen verdienten frei
zu leben sagte selenski bei einem
Treffen mit muslimischen Soldaten unter
ihnen auch Krim Tataren sowie die
Ukraine die Unversehrtheit anderer
Staaten Schätze verlange man auch
Respekt gegenüber der eigenen
Souveränität
der Krieg in der Ukraine ist auch das
zentrale Thema bei den Ostermärschen in
Deutschland bundesweit sind auch heute
wieder tausende Menschen auf die Straße
gegangen ihr gemeinsames Anliegen
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine lehnen
viele ab sie zu beenden forderte
beispielsweise die frühere
Ratsvorsitzende der Evangelischen Kirche
Käßmann in Hannover
auch ein Großteil der Linkspartei lehnt
Waffenlieferungen ab aber wie mit dem
ukrainekrieg und Russland umgegangen
werden soll dazu gibt es in der
Linkspartei unterschiedliche Ansichten
mehr dazu von Markus groß seit 22 Jahren
gehen in Potsdam friedensbewegte
Menschen auf die Straße zum ersten Mal
organisiert die Linke ihren eigenen
Ostermarsch sie konnte sich nicht mit
dem lokalen Friedensbündnis auf einen
gemeinsamen Aufruf einigen gekommen sind
nicht viele doch der Wunsch nach
Abrüstung 1 sie warfen Lieferung sein
der falsche Weg wir müssen die den Weg
zurück finden in die Diplomatie wir
brauchen ökonomischen Druck wir brauchen
auch politischen Druck und wir brauchen
eine Offensive der Diplomatie zusammen
mit China als Partei steht in der
Waffenlieferung sehr kritisch und
ablehnend gegenüber weil
Waffenlieferungen immer weitere
Waffenlieferungen natürlich die Risiken
einer weiteren Eskalation einer
Ausbreitung dieses Krieges und einer
Internationalisierung des Konfliktes
beinhalten und dagegen stellen wir uns
doch das Thema Waffenlieferung ist nicht
unumstritten in der Partei auch nicht
das Verhältnis zu Russland in der Partei
Rumo des kräftig
[Musik]
auf der einen Seite also Frau
Wagenknecht auf der anderen Seite ich
würde mal sagen das Aushängeschild der
Linken der einzige Ministerpräsident den
sich stellt wo du Ramelow der gegenüber
Russland eine kritische Position
einnimmt eine ganz andere Friedensdemo
findet zur gleichen Zeit am
Brandenburger Tor statt dort fordern
Ukrainerin und Ukraine Waffen für den
Frieden
niemand will Frieden so sehr wie Ukraine
und Ukrainerinnen aber wir verstehen das
jetzt gerade können wir den Waffen nicht
einfach weg liegen weil das bedeutet
kein Frieden das bedeutet mehr Krieg und
deswegen Waffenlieferung in ihrer
Performance sitzen die Friedenstauben in
Sicherheit am gedeckten Tisch ein
Seitenhieb auf die Friedensbewegungen in
Deutschland die Forderung nach
Waffenlosigkeit sei einfach wenn man
nicht selbst betroffen ist so die
Botschaft zu Ostern
die Lampe Koalition bringt weiter ums
Geld denn im nächsten Bundeshaushalt
Klasse eine Lücke von bis zu 18
Milliarden Euro sagte Finanzminister
Lindner der Rheinischen Post diese Lücke
müsste durch Verzicht gestopft und jeder
einzelne Ausgabe beraten werden die
Koalitionspartner SPD und Grüne
reagierten reserviert grünen
Fraktionsvize sagte Priorität müssen
unsere Kinder und sozialer Klimaschutz
haben
in mehreren Filialen des inservierten
Konzerns Galeria Kaufhof Karstadt haben
sich Beschäftigte an Warnstreiks
beteiligt betroffen waren insgesamt 19
Kaufhäuser in drei Bundesländern die
Gewerkschaft verdi fordert für die
17.000 Beschäftigten die Bezahlung nach
den Flächen Tarifverträgen des
Einzelhandels dort Verdi verdienen sie
im Monat im Moment 15% weniger
bundesweit sollen 47 der 129 Filialen
geschlossen werden mit einem Verlust von
etwa 4.000 Arbeitsplätzen
Abtreibung gehört zu den umstrittensten
Themen in den USA jetzt schlägt eine
Gerichtsentscheidung hohe Wellen so hat
ein Bundesgericht in Texas die Zulassung
einer der gängigsten abtreibungspillen
ausgesetzt und zwar für das gesamte Land
das US-Justizministerium legte Berufung
ein und das ganze landet wohl jetzt vor
dem Obersten Gerichtshof die
Einzelheiten von Benjamin Daniel
Homosexualität bezeichnet Richter
kasmeric als Störung Abtreibung für ihn
Teufelszeug der fünffache Vater und
texanische Bundesrichter hat eine
Entscheidung getroffen die das ganze
Land in Aufregung versetzt wieder mal
demnach soll die Abtreibungspille miffer
plus Ton ihre Zulassung verlieren
angeblich sei das Präparat unsicher und
vor seiner Einführung nicht ausreichend
durch die Arzneimittelbehörde FDA
geprüft worden die FDA hält dagegen vier
Jahre lang habe man das Medikament
getestet 99% der Frauen hätten keinerlei
Nebenwirkungen die US-Regierung hat
bereits eine Berufung angestrengt
der Präsident und ich stehen an der
Seite der amerikanischen Frauen wir
werden alles dafür tun dass Frauen die
Möglichkeit haben eigene Entscheidungen
zu treffen wenn es um Ihre Gesundheit
und Reproduktion geht mehr als die
Hälfte aller Schwangerschaftsabbrüche
werden in den USA medikamentös
eingeleitet nachdem der Supreme Court im
letzten Jahr das bundesweite Recht auf
Abtreibung aufgehoben hatte sind
abtreibungspillen für viele
Amerikanerinnen der letzte Ausweg aus
einer Notlage
konservative Kräfte versuchen nun das
Vertrauen in die Zulassungsbehörde FDA
zu erschüttern
es ist ermutigend dass sich die
bundesjustiz endlich mit der Zulassung
von miffure prestone auseinandersetzt
und die FDA in Verantwortung nimmt
ein anderer Richter im Bundesstaat
Washington urteilte hingegen dass die
Pille doch sicher sei und so rechnen
Beobachter damit dass sich bald der
Oberste Gerichtshof mit dem Streit
beschäftigen könnte
zurück nach Deutschland da nutzen viele
die Feiertage bei Ostern für eine
Auszeit endlich mal raus aus dem Alltag
verreisen durchschnaufen spätestens beim
Blick auf die Preise aber ist der Urlaub
schon nicht mehr ganz so unbekümmert
denn die Inflation hinterlässt auch am
Strand ihre Spuren an der Stadt fällt
war für uns in Warnemünde
mit dem Osterfest startet die
Tourismussaison Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
Ostsee und Sonnenschein locken die
ersten Urlauber besonders an die Küste
wie hier in Rostock Warnemünde letzte
Handgriffe in der Restaurantküche von
Carsten Loll dann kann das
Mittagsgeschäft beginnen aber dem
Gastronomen machen die stark gestiegenen
Stromkosten zu schaffen man darf es aber
nicht nur runterbrechen auf die
Energiekosten man muss wirklich auch die
Warenbeschaffung die waren Verfügbarkeit
Personalkosten alle sehen seine Ausgaben
sind um bis zu 30% gestiegen deshalb hat
er eine energiepauschale eingeführt
einen Euro 80 muss jeder Gast zusätzlich
zahlen entlang der Ostseeküste haben
Hoteliers und Gastronomen vielerorts an
der Preis Schraube gedreht in
Restaurants müssen Gäste bis zu 19% mehr
bezahlen für einige so unangenehm wie
ein Sprung ins kalte Wasser
teilweise bin ich der Meinung ist das
auch überspritzt und mal schaut auf die
Preise und sucht sich dann ist
günstigste raus wenn ich darauf achten
muss und gucken muss wo wie was ist dann
finde ich braucht man nicht in Urlaub
fahren auch Freizeiteinrichtungen wieder
Zoo in Rostock sind teurer geworden
wegen Inflation und gestiegenen Kosten
für Tierfutter die Tageskarte für
Erwachsene kostete vor einem Jahr noch
17,50 € jetzt
23,50 €. wie finanzieren über die
Einnahmen der Eintrittspreise unsere
Betriebskosten dann die Versorgung der
seltenen und zum Teil hochbedrohten
Tierarten höhere Preise aber
gleichzeitig müssen sich Urlauber auf
weniger Service einstellen durch
Fachkräftemangel eingeschränkte
Öffnungszeiten und mehr Ruhetage sind
die Folgen insgesamt geht das
Ostergeschäft leicht zurück die Branche
rechnet mit 8% weniger Auslastung
und jetzt kommen wir zum Sport da freuen
sich Deutschland Fußball Frauen die aber
den ersten Sieg des Jahres genau und
zwar in einem sogenannten Prestige
Duellen das Team von Martina Voss
Tecklenburg gewann bei den
vize-weltmeisterinnen in den
Niederlanden mit 1:0 es war das erste
von zwei Testspielen rund um die
Ostertage ein glücklicher Sieg 108 Tage
vor Beginn der WM
Sydney Lohmann erzählt das Tor des
Abends nach einer Standardsituation Ecke
klarer Bühl schwache Verteidigung der
Niederlande das Siegtor in der 53 Minute
trotz Chancen plus der
niederländerinhalten da sind wir immer
gefährlich das zeichnet uns noch aus und
deswegen ist trotzdem schön auch so ein
Spiel ein Stück weit dreckig zu gewinnen
denn es spielt vor allem ein team orange
mit Merle froms und nach der Pause
Ann-Kathrin Berger hat die DFB-Elf aber
schon starke Torhüterinnen in WM-Form
Laura Freigang verpasst kurz vor Schluss
den zweiten Treffer für Deutschland ich
bin froh dass uns die Niederlande
einfach auch vor Probleme gestellt hat
weil daraus können wir lernen nächste
Gelegenheit am Dienstag gegen Brasilien
und in der Fußball-Bundesliga der Männer
ist Bayern München die pokalrevanche
gegen SC Freiburg geglückt vier Tage
nach dem Aus im Viertelfinale siebten
die Bayern diesmal in Freiburg mit 1:0
hier sind die samstags Ergebnisse
Mattheis de Lift erzielt den Siegtreffer
für die Bayern Dortmund Union Berlin 2:1
Leverkusen Frankfurt 3:1 Mainz Werder
Bremen 22 Augsburg Köln 123 und das
Abendspiel Hertha gegen Leipzig
ausführlich bei uns im Aktuellen
Sportstudio in der Tabelle bleibt
Dortmund mit zwei Punkten Rückstand
erster Verfolger der Bayern keine
Veränderung bis Platz 5 Leverkusen jetzt
vor Eintracht Frankfurt die zweite
Hälfte beginnt mit Gladbach Köln zieht
an Augsburg vorbei Schalke und Stuttgart
auf den direkten Abstiegsplätzen 17 und
18 Spielen aber beide noch morgen alles
zum Spieltag wie gewohnt bei uns im
Aktuellen Sportstudio von 23 Uhr an Gast
im Studio Werder Bremen Trainer Ole
Werner
und Deutschlands Eishockey Frauen haben
bei der WM in Kanada eine erste
Niederlage hinnehmen müssen nach dem
überragenden sechs zu zwei Auftakt gegen
Schweden verloren die Auswahl mit 023
gegen Finnland
die deutschen stemmen sich gegen die
Niederlage doch die Finninnen zeigen
sich als das erwartet starke Top-Team
technisch überlegen und treffsicher rosa
Lindstedt und nicht mal drei Minuten
später Emilia Facer Finnland 2:0 Führung
nach dem ersten Drittel im Mittel
Drittel Laura kluge mit der besten
Gelegenheit für die DEB Frauen die Tore
macht Finnland wie wie weinacker und
Kurt erst das deutsche Tor und trifft
dann zum 3 zu 0 in der Nacht zu
Ostermontag das nächste Gruppenspiel
gegen Frankreich
die deutsche Reiterin Jessica von Bredo
Werndl hat erneut mit einer
Glanzleistung das Finale im
dressurweltcup gewonnen dank einer
perfekt abgestimmten Choreographie
gewann die Olympiasiegerin auf ihrer
Stute der Lehrer die Kühe in Omaha USA
Isabel Wert wurde mit ihrem Hengst
quantastete
und das war's danke schön Rudi heute vor
50 Jahren ist einer der größten Maler
aller Zeiten gestorben Pablo Picasso der
Schöpfer unter anderem der berühmten
Friedenstaube Wasser mit dem Pinsel
kreierte schaffte Italiener Dario
gambarin mit dem Traktor der
Aktionskünstler mäht immer wieder Motive
ins Feld wie hier in der Provinz Verona
zu dem riesenportrait inspiriert habe
ihn ein Selbstbildnis des spanischen
Künstlers aus dem Jahr 1907 Picasso
wurde übrigens 91 Jahre alt
das Wetter über Ostern wird für die
meisten sonnig und mild die Einzelheiten
hat gleich Katja horneffer für Sie das
heute journal können Sie heute um 22:45
Uhr sehen moderiert von Christian
Sievers schönen Samstagabend noch
[Musik]
guten Abend das war ja in den
vergangenen Tagen ziemlich frisch es
wird sich jetzt aber über die
Osterfeiertage ändern vorerst gab es ja
ein windows-östlichen Richtung jetzt
aber dreht die Strömung auf Süd bis
Südwest und erst in der Nacht auf
Dienstag beendet dann diese Kaltfront
das sonnige und milde Intermezzo heute
Nacht fällt am Alpenrand noch etwas
Regen sonst ist es häufig nur locker
bewölkt und das bildet sich Nebel unter
den etwas dichteren Wolken im Westen und
dem Norden sinken die Temperaturen auf 6
bis 2 Grad sonst geht's auf plus ein bis
-1° runter und morgen liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 9 Grad an
den Alpen und 16 Grad am Oberrhein oder
auch im Emsland und allenfalls ganz im
Osten ist ein kleines bisschen Regen
nicht ganz ausgeschlossen sonst muss ich
erst Nebel und Hochnebel auflösen und
dann zeigt sich häufiger mal die Sonne
bei Ost Südostwind der Ostermontag dann
aber bringt strahlende Sonnenschein
besonders in der Mitte und im Süden
Deutschland und mit Südwind klettern die
Temperaturen am Oberrhein bis 19 Grad
das sollten sie ausnutzen denn schon ab
Dienstag wird es deutlich wechselhafter
regnerischer zum Teil auch mit Gewittern
und wieder kühler frohe Ostern